.
Ein Luzerner Unternehmer
kämpft um seine Firma.
Wir möchten sie nicht entlassen.
Wir möchten ja nur arbeiten.
Corona bringt das Unternehmen
zum Stillstand.
Es tut weh, es tut mir selber weh.
Eine Künstlerin muss alles absagen.
Es ist so,
dass ich momentan keinen Lohn habe.
Corona gefährdet ihre Existenz.
Ich bin froh um den Sozialstaat
und möchte ihn nicht aushöhlen.
Luzerns grösster Souvenirhändler
ist fassungslos:
Man konnte sich nicht vorstellen,
dass eine Pandemie
solche Auswirkungen haben kann.
Der Touristen-Hotspot ist leer.
Wir sind darauf angewiesen,
dass wieder Touristen kommen.
Und: Zwei Luzerner Freunde
betreiben ein Hotel.
Sie geben alles,
um das Haus zu retten.
Es macht auch traurig,
wenn so wenig Leute kommen.
Jetzt gilt wirklich nur noch:
Vollgas vorwärts.
Ihre Geschichten in:
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Luzern im Frühherbst 2020.
Das milde Wetter
zieht die Menschen nach draussen.
Die COVID-19-Fallzahlen
sind niedrig,
steigen aber leicht an auf schweiz-
weit 500 Neuansteckungen pro Tag.
Im Hotel Beau Séjour wird es nach
dem vielbeschäftigten Sommer ruhig.
Je nach Geschäftsgang
ist auch die Gefühlslage der
Betreiber ein stetiges Auf und Ab.
Wenn den 35-jährigen Hoteldirektor
Manuel Berger Zweifel packen,
hilft der Gang
in den hauseigenen Boxkeller.
Der ansonsten so besonnene
Hoteldirektor Manuel schlägt zu.
Ein Sinnbild dafür,
wie das Corona-Jahr zu einem immer
längeren Kampf für uns alle wird.
Das ist einfach so ... Dabei kann
man nicht noch viel denken.
Man powert sichaus.
Dieser Sport macht mir mega Spass.
Dabei vergesse ich
so ziemlich alles.
Man kann gar nicht nachdenken.
Man muss sich sehr konzentrieren.
Aber es tut extrem gut.
* Sizilianischer Gesang:
Abballati, aballati" von Pino Villa *
#Abballati, abballati,
# fimmini schetti e maritati.
Bitte?
Nicht gut?
Näher.
- Ah, näher.
Sprecht doch deutlich!
Auf der Brache in Emmenbrücke
wird die Rettung des alten Varietés
Caleidoskop gefeiert.
* Gesang *
Claudia Kienzler hat die Schaubude
einen Monat vor dem Shutdown
im Frühling übernommen.
Hoi, André.- Wie geht's dir?
- Gut, und dir?
Freust du dich?
- Ja, mega. Ich bin etwas aufgeregt.
Zum ersten Mal können Freunde
und Gönnerinnen des Varietés
den Stand
der Renovationsarbeiten begutachten.
Bei dir darf ich auch.
- Ja, bei mir darfst du.
Auch Claudias Mutter ist gekommen,
und mit ihr die ganze Familie.
Es ist so schön.
Ich freue mich mega.
Dich darf ich auch?
Das ist Familie!
Ein Verein hat das Varieté gekauft.
Als Geschäftsführerin kämpft Claudia
um dessen Weiterexistenz.
Heute will sie mit der Unterstützung
ihres Freundes Christoph
den Gönnerinnen und Gönnern
die finanzielle Situation aufzeigen.
Wir fanden, so lange es noch warm
ist, wollen wir die Türen öffnen
und diesen Raum der Kultur
und der Musik übergeben.
Dafür ist er ja auch gedacht
und dafür mache ich auch alles.
Das Publikum geniesst den Anlass.
Aber für Claudia geht es um mehr.
Für den Betrieb
muss sie 200'000 Fr. auftreiben.
Es freut mich mega,
ich bin etwas aufgeregt.
Es freut mich mega, dass ihr hier
seid und das Interesse habt,
das ehemalige Broadway-Varieté
weiterzuverfolgen.
Es bleibt Spiel- und Verzehrtheater.
Es ist mein Wunsch,
dass auch die Kulinarik
sehr viel näher am
künstlerischen Programm sein wird.
Das ist mit ein Grund, dass
die Küche sehr viel präsenter ist.
Sie hat eine eigene Bühne bekommen.
Es gibt hier noch das Buffet,
den Spielplatz, wie wir ihn nennen,
also die ganze Luftartistik wird
auch hier oben vor dem Eingang sein.
Es sind
riesige Investitionsleistungen,
die jetzt getätigt werden müssen.
Das ist aktuell ...
Natürlich, wenn man gewillt ist
aktiv einen Beitrag an die
Anschubfinanzierung zu leisten.
Und dann künftig auch durch
eine Mitgliedschaft im Gönnerverein.
Jeder Zuschuss - ob gross
oder klein - ist willkommen.
Denn ohne Spendengelder
droht dem Varietéprojekt das Aus.
Das ist einfach mein Dank.
Ohne euch wäre ich aufgeschmissen.
* Bluegrass-Country *
Das Fest gibt schon mal einen
Vorgeschmack auf die Varietétournee.
Im Frühling 2021
wollen Claudia und ihr Team
mit Akrobatik, Tanztheater und
Kulinarik durch die Schweiz tingeln -
so der Plan.
* Bluegrass-Country *
Roland Küng, der CEO des
Zeltbauunternehmens Hunziker AG,
trifft seine Berufskollegen
vom neu gegründeten Dachverband.
Sie alle hat die Krise
mit grosser Wucht getroffen.
Wie ist das allgemeine Befinden?
Wir sind bei 15-20 % Umsatz,
den wir jetzt noch machen können,
den wir machen müssen. Wo bist du?
Also jetzt?
- Ja.
So wie ich
die Lage aktuell einschätze,
werden wir 75-80 % Umsatzverlust
eines normalen Jahres haben.
Wir haben im Moment also ...
Im Moment kommt
der eine oder andere Event rein.
Wir mussten Massnahmen ergreifen,
z.B. Leute entlassen.
Wir mussten fünf Personen entlassen.
Von daher gesehen,
ist es sehr schwierig.
Wir sehen den Horizont,
aber der ist sehr düster.
Wir mussten auch Leute entlassen.
Wir sehen wirklich nicht sehr weit.
2021 wird sicher auch ...
... nicht gut.
Aber voilà -
wir können nichts dafür.
Wir können nur hoffen,
und ich hoffe auf Hilfe.
Man kann nicht alle Zeltbauer,
Eventbauer im Stich lassen.
Darum habe ich das Gefühl,
dass politisch ...
Du lachst jetzt, aber ...
Nein, aber es sind Verwaltungen,
Politiker, Ärzte,
die uns Gesetze machen.
Sie sagen uns im Moment,
was wir dürfen und was nicht.
Und niemand übernimmt
die Verantwortung - niemand.
Man hat keine Sicherheit.
Du kannst die gesamte Infrastruktur
aufgebaut haben
und am Tag der Türöffnung
wird die Durchführung abgesagt.
Man muss sich bewusst sein:
Wir haben seit dem 28. Februar 2020
keine Arbeit
und ich spreche vom Sommer 2021,
in dem wahrscheinlich nichts läuft.
Da ist man schon irgendwann
an einem Punkt, an dem man sagt,
... an dem man
nervös oder ungehalten wird
und das System anzweifelt.
Wir möchten eigentlich
nichts anderes tun als arbeiten
und mit unseren Mitarbeitern
Geld verdienen.
Wir möchten sie nicht entlassen.
Noch im Sommer
hat Roland Küng seiner Belegschaft
ein grosses Versprechen abgegeben:
keine Kündigungen
bis Ende Jahr.
Im Herbst gehört die Touristenstadt
Luzern wieder den Einheimischen.
Der Sommer fiel dank Schweizer Gästen
für einige Hotels
besser aus als befürchtet.
So auch beim Hotel Beau Séjour.
Das beflügelt Direktor Manuel Berger.
Das Hotel
war zur Hälfte ausgebucht - immerhin.
Dank Spezialangeboten
und dem Sommerkiosk.
Ich glaube, dass wir uns immer auf
Individualgäste konzentriert haben,
macht einiges aus.
Das ist aber nicht nur
eine Ausrichtung unseres Konzepts.
Das hat auch mit unserem Hotel zu
tun, dass wir nur 28 Zimmer haben.
Es würde logistisch und von den
Räumlichkeiten her nicht gehen,
dass wir grosse Gruppen hätten,
also Cartourismus.
Natürlich geht es den Hotels,
die viel Gruppentourismus haben,
jetzt nicht gut.
Es fällt alles weg,
wenn man mit Reisegruppen aus Asien,
Indien und China zusammenarbeitet.
Das wurde alles gecancelt.
Doch jetzt,
mit den kälteren Herbsttagen,
kehrt auch die Unsicherheit
im kleinen Boutiquehotel zurück.
Es ist Ende Oktober.
Die Neuansteckungen steigen an,
auf über 9'000 pro Tag.
Die zweite Pandemiewelle
hat die Schweiz voll erfasst.
Restaurants
müssen um 23 Uhr schliessen.
Anlässe über 50 Personen
werden verboten.
Doch kleinere Kulturanlässe
sind noch möglich.
Monatelang hat Claudia Kienzler
mit dem Ensemble
für ein Theaterstück geprobt.
Heute ist Premiere - das Lampenfieber
dementsprechend gross!
Jetzt ist jeder individuell nervös.
Um 10 Uhr kommen wir zusammen.
- Das überlasse ich dir.
Ich bin nicht so nervös.
Ich bin einfach nervös,
weil mein Mami kommt.
Nach 40 Jahren immer noch?
Ähm, 10 Uhr würde ich sagen.
Ist das gut?
Gut.
- Sonst schreist du, wenn etwas ist.
Ja.
* Kim schreit. *
* Lockere Musik *
Die Tickets sind begehrt und
alle drei Vorstellungen ausverkauft.
Das Stück für Kinder
dreht sich um das Leben,
die Freundschaft und den Tod.
Wieso ausgerechnet ich?
Hä?
Du musst mir einfach sagen, wann,
wo und wie ich sterbe - sonst ...
Eine Ente ist wütend
und hadert mit dem Tod.
Doch dann freunden sich
die beiden an.
Am Ende kann die Ente
in Frieden sterben.
Wie Kindern den Tod erklären?
In Corona-Zeiten
gewinnt diese Frage an Aktualität.
* Applaus *
Endlich wieder
eine Theatervorstellung
und endlich wieder ein Verdienst!
Einen solchen Applaus
hätten wohl alle Kulturschaffenden,
die harte Zeiten durchleben,
verdient.
Das ist mega.
- Ja, sie sind aufgestanden.
Bei einer Standing Ovation
geht das Herz auf.
Und ich habe sowieso ...
Ich meine, ich war immer am Spielen,
am warmhalten
und habe
zusammen mit Leuten gespielt.
Aber ich habe gemerkt,
wie lange ich solchen Applaus
nicht mehr erlebt habe.
Das ist krass eingefahren.
Dieses Glück
kann Claudia nochmals geniessen.
Alle Vorstellungen finden statt.
Aber dann muss das Theater
wegen Corona wieder schliessen.
* Akzentuierte, dumpfe Klänge *
Nur ein Jahr vor dem ersten Shutdown
hat Casagrande
in ein neues Geschäft investiert.
Nicht wie bisher Souvenirs,
sondern Luxusprodukte
sollten gut betuchte Touristen,
aber auch Einheimische anziehen.
Ein Vogel pfeift,
der andere antwortet.
Das sind Fasanenfedern,
die dort eingebaut sind.
Alles, was man sieht,
ist 24 Karat Gold.
Es ist ein wahnsinniges Werk.
Es ist eigentlich ein Staatsgeschenk
der Schweizer Eidgenossenschaft.
Wenn Bundesräte ins Ausland gehen,
wird meistens das verschenkt.
* Trillern *
6'500 Fr. muss einem
der goldene Käfig wert sein.
Aber Abnehmer gibt es keine.
Die Nachfrage nach Luxusprodukten
ist eingebrochen.
Fast alle Casagrande-Filialen
sind geschlossen,
über 100 Angestellte in Kurzarbeit.
Dieses Geschäft bleibt zwar offen,
doch auf Kundschaft
wartet das Personal vergebens.
Wir haben sehr viel Geld investiert.
Man kann sagen:
3,7 Mio. in den Umbau
und 2,2 Mio.
in den Warenlageraufbau.
Das hat immense Summen verschlungen.
Am 1. Mai vor einem Jahr
haben wir eröffnet.
Und ... äh ...
Es lief gut.
Dann war im März
natürlich abrupt Schluss damit.
Wir sind wirklich darauf angewiesen,
dass die Touristen wiederkommen.
Mit Personalschulungen wollte
Casagrande die Flaute überbrücken -
doch auch die
sind jetzt infrage gestellt.
Hallo, Paulo.
Die Face-Behandlung-Schulung wird
am 2. November nicht durchgeführt,
wenn heute der Bundesrat
entscheidet,
dass dies
für mehrere Personen verboten ist.
Und ich erwarte, dass das
für den Moment abgesagt wird.
Wir können das erst später machen.
- Okay.
Casagrande
ist vorläufig noch liquid.
Aber wir sitzen
mit unseren Vermietern zusammen
und versuchen,
mit ihnen Lösungen zu finden,
damit sie uns
bei der Miete entgegenkommen.
Das ist bist jetzt
noch nicht geschehen.
Wir bereiten Gespräche
mit den Banken vor
und hoffen natürlich sehr
auf die Härtefallklausel.
Denn mit mehr
als 90 % Rückgang der Einnahmen
ist das für uns
eine sehr schlimme Situation.
Das Privatvermögen schmilzt.
Im Prinzip tut mir meine Hand weh.
Ich muss jeden Tag mein Portemonnaie
aus der Tasche nehmen, öffnen
und wieder Geld
in die Firma einschiessen.
Und ja, das ist sehr viel Geld.
Nur wenige Meter
vom Luxusgeschäft entfernt,
befindet sich
das Mutterhaus von Casagrande.
Auch wenn keine Touristen
vor den Vitrinen drängeln,
wie in Zeiten vor Corona,
gibt es für den Hauswart
immer etwas zu tun.
Bojan Jovanovic arbeitet seit 25
Jahren hier und ist stets zur Stelle,
wenn es Probleme gibt.
Ich sehe nichts.
Wenn ich einstecke, blinkt es.
Oben komme ich nicht dran.
Der Ladenbauer
hat die Vitrine so konstruiert.
Jetzt muss ich versuchen,
von der inneren Seite ranzukommen.
* Piepen *
Ups, Alarm.
Mission Impossible!
Solche Sachen sieht man nicht.
Man sieht nur alles schön leuchten.
Das ist gut und recht,
aber wenn etwas nicht funktioniert,
muss ich schauen,
wie ich das Problem lösen kann.
Und mit solchen Sachen
befassen sich wenige Leute.
Dann ist Bojan da.
Yeah, geschafft.
No paper.
Manuel Berger und seinem
Geschäftspartner Walter Willimann
steht im Hotel Beau Séjour
ein wichtiges Treffen bevor.
Denn es steht nicht gut
um das 28-Zimmer-Haus.
In den Wintermonaten
buchen nur wenige Gäste.
Trotzdem
belaufen sich die Betriebskosten
auf gegen 30'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Peter Kiener
ist der Besitzer des Hotels.
Auch ihm
machen die tiefroten Zahlen Sorgen.
Und der Bundesrat
verschärft die Massnahmen weiter.
Kiener sieht die Not der Betreiber
und kommt ihnen grosszügig entgegen.
Wir schauen uns dann
den Jahresabschluss an.
Und die Miete ist eigentlich ...
Von der Fixmiete
gingen wir auf den Umsatz.
Nachdem wir
die Bücher angeschaut haben,
schauen wir, wie die Miete aussieht.
Und dann ... ja ...
Wir hoffen, dass wir trotzdem
gewisse Kosten bezahlen können.
Ich bin davon überzeugt,
dass es wieder weitergeht.
Ich glaube,
wenn man ein Hotel mietet,
kann man nicht besser unterstützt
sein als von Peter und Esther.
Peter ist weiterhin bereit,
in dieses Haus zu investieren.
Und ich glaube,
Peter ist der angenehmste Vermieter,
den ich je hatte.
- Danke schön.
Und gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich
auch der cleverste von allen,
weil er weiss: Wenn es uns gut geht,
geht es uns allen gut.
Das Hotel
hat Peter Kiener von einem Freund,
der keine Nachkommen hatte, geerbt.
Er glaubt an Manuel und Willy
und ihre kreativen Ideen.
In der grössten Krise
bauen wir eine Sonnenterrasse
für den nächsten Sommer.
Wenn ich mit Peter bespreche,
dass der Kostenpunkt der Handwerker
nicht so hoch ist,
wenn wir selber Hand anlegen -
so wie sich das gehört -
dann ist Peter
für solche Sachen immer zu haben.
Dann machen wir das einfach.
Wir sind beide Krampfer, alle
anderen um uns herum natürlich auch.
Es macht uns nichts aus,
das selber zu machen.
Einfach 10 cm runter,
und dann ist es gut.
Peter Kiener besitzt eine Wäscherei,
auch die spürt die Krise.
Trotzdem
bleibt er ein sozialer Unternehmer
und ist sich nicht zu schade,
mitanzupacken.
Wenn es die Zeit erlaubt,
mache ich das gerne.
Dann weiss man auch,
wie viel Arbeit das macht.
Es ist auch schön,
draussen zu arbeiten.
Trotz unsicheren Perspektiven bleibt
Kiener gelassen und optimistisch.
Das Hotel,
überhaupt die Gastronomie,
hat eine Zukunft,
die wiederkommt.
Ich denke, das Virus
hat jetzt alles lahmgelegt,
aber eine Zukunft muss es ja geben.
Sonst haben wir dann
eine Terrasse für uns.
Das ist so.
* Lockere Musik *
Dafür, dass wir das noch nie gemacht
haben, kommen wir gut voran.
Super, ich würde sagen,
wir haben das in Rekordzeit gemacht.
Jetzt können wir
am Nachmittag jassen.- Ja, genau.
Hast du auch Muskelkater?
- Sehr.
Der Umbau der Terrasse sorgt nicht
nur für Muskelkater und Hunger,
sondern auch für neue Kosten.
Was haben wir gesagt,
was alles zusammen kostet?
Wahrscheinlich ca. 24'000?
So steht es auf der Offerte.
Ca. 24'000.
Hohe Kosten, tiefe Einnahmen,
und wieder greift der Besitzer
in die Tasche.
V.a. Peter, das darf man so sagen.
Peter bezahlt.
Wir hoffen natürlich immer,
dass Peter mit solchen Sachen,
die er ins Haus investiert,
irgendwann auch partizipieren kann,
wenn wir mit unserer Terrasse
entsprechend gute Umsätze machen.
Die Idee wäre ja, dass sie uns
etwas einbringt.- Genau.
Gut, die Terrasse
hält dann auch 20 Jahre.
Das ist so. Das ist
ein langfristiges Investment.
Danke. En Guete.
En Guete, miteinander.
Einen verheissungsvollen Namen
für die neue Terrasse
hat Manuel auch schon:
Beau Séjour Lido.
* Sanfte Harmonikaklänge *
Nur wenige 100 m Luftlinie
vom Varieté in Emmenbrücke entfernt
gibt es ein ganz spezielles Dorf.
Es besteht aus lauter Wagen
und ist das Zuhause
der Musikerin Claudia Kienzler.
Die 39-jährige Künstlerin hat sich
hier ein einfaches Leben aufgebaut.
Ihr Zuhause ist naturnah,
nachhaltig und mobil.
Eigentlich hat sich das so ergeben.
Ich kannte Leute,
die in Wagen wohnen.
Ich selber
habe nie in einem Wagen gewohnt,
bis ich zur Schaustellerei kam.
Da war es für mich klar,
dass ich meinen eigenen Wagen baue.
Claudia hat sich bewusst
für diesen unkonventionellen
Lebensstil entschieden.
Denn Freiheit
ist für sie der grösste Luxus.
Auch wenn es
manchmal viel Arbeit macht.
Als Erstes feuert man am Morgen ein.
Ich mag es, bei frischen ...
Ich erwache gerne
bei frischen Temperaturen.
Claudia hat momentan nur das feste
Einkommen ihres kleinen Pensums
als Musikdozentin
und Violine-Lehrerin.
Obwohl sie Ausfallentschädigung
vom Kanton erhält,
reicht das nicht zum Leben.
Darum muss sie
auf Erspartes zurückgreifen.
Das ist vielleicht etwas fahrlässig.
Ich habe kaum eine Altersvorsorge.
Meine Altersvorsorge
liegt eigentlich auf dem Sparkonto.
Die wird jetzt gebraucht.
Vielleicht bin ich jetzt froh,
dass das Geld zur Verfügung steht
und nicht in einer 3. Säule steckt.
Das war aber
eigentlich nicht der Plan.
Es war eher der Plan,
das sauber aufzugleisen,
damit ich etwas für meine Pension
auf die Seite legen kann.
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Die würden kosten.
Das ist sicher ein grosser ...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Das ist etwas, das ich spare.
Diesen Aufwand habe ich nicht.
Mir ist extrem bewusst,
welche Freiheiten ich habe,
weil ich keine Kinder habe.
Ab und zu ist mir aber sehr bewusst,
was ich noch gerne hätte
und mir vorstellen könnte,
nämlich Mutter zu sein.
Das wechselt sich manchmal ab.
Aber es ... ähm ...
Wenn ich ohne Kinder sterbe
oder älter werde,
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
ich habe grundsätzlich
irgendein Lebensziel verfehlt.
Die ungewisse Zukunft
zehrt an den Nerven
und die ständige Bereitschaft
zur Flexibilität ermüdet.
Umso wichtiger sind für die Musikerin
Momente der Ruhe.
Denn nur wer frei im Kopf ist,
kann kreativ sein.
* Gemütliche Klänge *
Bojan Jovanovic, dem Mann
für alle Fälle bei Casagrande,
haben es Uhren besonders angetan.
Mit viel Leidenschaft erledigt er
einfache Reparaturarbeiten.
Doch seit ein paar Tagen
stehen für Bojan
die Zeichen der Zeit leider schlecht.
Wie aus heiterem Himmel
hat er die Kündigung erhalten.
Natürlich habe ich in dem Moment
die Welt nicht mehr verstanden.
Corona, keine Touristen,
das Geschäft läuft nicht so gut
und plötzlich
bist du nicht mehr angestellt.
Was heisst das für mich?
Was heisst das für die Familie,
die Kinder?
Die Kinder sind in Ausbildung.
Wenn ich keine Arbeit habe -
was kann ich machen?
Man beginnt sich so viele Sachen zu
überlegen, denkt über vieles nach,
aber es ist ein Schock.
Auch den CEO
der Zeltbaufirma Hunziker AG
zwingt die Corona-Krise in die Knie.
Roland Küng sieht sich gezwungen,
sein Versprechen an die Belegschaft
zu brechen.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Noch vor einem Monat
war mein absolutes Ziel:
An Weihnachten
haben alle Mitarbeiter
einen Job, eine Stelle,
eine sichere Stelle bei uns.
Aber ja ...
Es geht
schlicht und einfach nicht mehr.
Wir mussten jetzt reagieren
und jetzt leider
sechs Mitarbeiter entlassen.
Schon der ganze
Prozess der Entscheidung,
welche Leute es trifft -
das zerreisst einen.
Und trotzdem ist es meine Aufgabe,
allen anderen einen sicheren
Arbeitsplatz zu bieten,
die Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Und dann, sich hinzusetzen
und es den Leuten zu kommunizieren.
Sie können nichts dafür, die
Geschäftsleitung kann nichts dafür.
Aber jetzt müssen wir diese Mass-
nahmen ergreifen. Das ist brutal.
Jetzt steht
das letzte Kündigungsgespräch an.
Eine Mitarbeiterin
verliert ihren Job -
nach vielen Jahren in der Firma.
* Gemütliche Musik *
Hallo.
- Hallo, alles klar?
Hauswart Bojan Jovanovic
muss auf Ende Jahr gehen,
trotzdem ist auf ihn
nach wie vor Verlass.
Am schlimmsten sind die Bildschirme
drüben, die schwarz werden.
Hier haben wir eine Lichterkette,
die sich ... ja, aber ...
Ich muss schauen,
wo das Netzteil ist.
Wenn man lötet, geht das lange.
Aber wenn man das Ding auswechselt,
kommt es wieder.
Dort drüben
schaut noch ein Kabel raus.
Auf Bojan lastet die Aussicht schwer,
dass er in wenigen Wochen
ohne Arbeit sein wird.
Er ist einer von zehn Angestellten,
denen gekündigt worden ist.
Ja, es ist natürlich sehr, sehr hart
für jede einzelne Person.
Die Diskussionen in der
Geschäftsleitung gingen über Tage,
bis man entschieden hatte,
welche Positionen wir
im Moment nicht brauchen.
Leider ist es jetzt seine und andere
Positionen, bei denen man sagt,
dass wir in den nächsten drei bis
vier Jahren keine Erholung sehen.
Es ist besser,
solange die Leute noch jung sind
und die Möglichkeit haben,
etwas anderes zu finden.
Bojan ist sicher einer, der auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt noch gute Chancen hat,
weil er sehr viel kann.
Bojan ist 50
und Vater von zwei Töchtern.
Beide sind mitten im Studium.
Seine Frau Nina hat einen Teilzeitjob
als Verkäuferin.
Salü.
- Salü.
Bist du fertig?
- Jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ab und zu leisten sich die beiden
ein Mittagessen im Thai-Restaurant.
Noch dürfen Gastronomie-Betriebe
geöffnet haben.
Vielen Dank.
Ich nehme es mit Tofu.
Danke schön.
Marietta hat Raffaela
zwei Uhren gegeben.
Bei denen kann ich
die Batterien wechseln.
Crevetten?
- Ja, für mich.
Wow, das sieht sehr schön aus.
Vielen Dank.
Ah, lecker!
Oje.- En Guete.
- Vielen Dank.- Danke schön.
Heute ist es speziell gut.
Bojan hat Nina
erst in der Schweiz kennengelernt.
Die beiden
sind schon lange ein Paar.
Zusammen haben sie
Höhen und Tiefen durchgemacht.
Und jetzt die Kündigung.
Ich habe sie nicht erwartet.
Ehrlich gesagt, war ich schockiert.
V.a. bei ihm
habe ich es nicht erwartet.
Ich dachte:
"Er ist jemand, der alles macht."
Ausserdem ist er schon lange dabei.
Das habe ich ...
Es hat mich schon etwas schockiert.
Es ist schwierig zu sagen.
Wir wissen nicht,
was jetzt auf uns zukommt.
Die Hoffnung nicht verlieren
und versuchen,
das Beste daraus zu machen.
Es reicht nicht,
wenn nur eine Person arbeitet.
Es müssen beide berufstätig sein,
um zu überleben.
Um Rechnungen zu bezahlen.
- Genau, genau.
Und sich ein gutes Essen
im Restaurant zu gönnen.
* Nina lacht. *
Wie Bojan ergeht es vielen Menschen
in der Schweiz.
Innerhalb eines Jahres
steigt die Zahl der Arbeitslosen
von 120'000 auf 170'000 an.
Roland Küng
erlebt seine schwierigste Zeit
als Chef der Festzeltfirma
Hunziker AG.
Wegen der Krise musste er
sechs Kündigungen aussprechen.
Soeben hat er das letzte
Entlassungsgespräch geführt.
Ja, es ist  ... äh ...
... schwer.
Gerade das letzte war sehr schwer.
Die Distanz wahren ...
Also Distanz wahren heisst,
nicht auf Diskussionen eingehen,
weil sie in dieser Situation
für den Mitarbeiter oder
die Mitarbeiterin nichts bringen.
Aber es ist natürlich
ein riesiges Thema: "Wieso ich?"
Das begreife ich.
Ja, es ist schwer.
Es ist einfach nur schwer,
wenn man zur Arbeit geht und weiss:
Heute ...
Ich wäre nicht dafür gemacht,
um das immer und immer wieder
zu machen.
Nein, das ist nicht schön,
definitiv nicht.
Das tut weh, es tut mir selber weh.
Für die Leute und ihre Angehörigen.
* Traurige Klänge *
Vor Weihnachten
gilt wieder die Phase rot.
Die Massnahmen
werden noch restriktiver.
Trotzdem wollen viele nicht
auf Weihnachtseinkäufe verzichten.
Der Bundesrat schliesst
alle Restaurant- Kultur-
und Freizeitbetriebe.
Die Folgen der wirtschaftlichen
Misere werden immer sichtbarer.
Sogar das Fünfsternehotel
Schweizerhof,
wo schon die englische
Königin übernachtet hat,
schliesst im Januar
für drei Monate seine Tore.
Auch das Hotel Beau Séjour geht
für sechs Wochen in den Winterschlaf.
Vorne können wir offen lassen,
es wird sowieso schmutzig.
Manuel Berger will die Zeit
für Renovationen nutzen.
Doch die Frage bleibt:
Wie wird es weitergehen?
Es ist schon etwas painful,
wenn man frisch gemachte Betten
wieder abzieht.
Im ersten Lockdown
hatte ich das Gefühl,
nach eineinhalb Monaten
ist der Spass wieder vorbei.
Das ist offenbar nicht so.
Das sind die Momente,
indenen man Angst hat, dass es das
nun war mit der Hotellerie.
Oder dass sich alles nicht in
absehbarer Zeit wieder normalisiert.
Das ist eben das, was mir
manchmal etwas Angst macht.
Das Jahr voller Unsicherheit
ist anstrengend für den Hotelier,
der das Haus
vor drei Jahren übernommen hat
und so ganz andere Pläne hatte.
Zwar musste niemand entlassen werden,
doch jetzt scheint es,
dass auch Manuel
langsam von Corona-Müdigkeit
erfasst wird.
Raus hier.
Das Hotel wird geschlossen.
Währenddessen weht
die Fahne auf Halbmast.
Das ist schon etwas deprimierend.
Das ist,
wie wenn Staaten in Trauer
um ihren König
oder ihre Königin sind.
Wir trauern,
weil wir schliessen mussten.
In der letzten Folge: Hauswart
Bojan Jovanovic ist auf Arbeitssuche.
Es ist ein böses Erwachen,
weil ich mich nicht verkaufen will.
Ich bin so, wie ich bin.
CEO Roland Küng wird von seinem Chef
einbestellt. Der will expandieren.
Es sind grosse Chancen. Wir sind in
dem Markt der grosse Silberrücken.
Wenn wir die Gelegenheit haben,
die Ausweitung in der Schweiz hinzu-
bekommen, prüfen wir das sehr genau.
Und das Varieté wäre schon fast
bereit für die Tournee.
Auftritt Chrigu, Auftritt.
Chrigu!
Ich glaube, die Menschen
freuen sich sehr darauf,
dass die Vorhänge wieder aufgehen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Liz Lei - 2021